[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
all right well our old sort of friend
milo yiannopoulos is back in the news i
don't know how many of you remember milo
yiannopoulos
how do you even describe who milo
yiannopoulos was a right-wing
uh gay guy who is also catholic
who would sort of deflate a lot of the
homophobic attacks against the right by
saying he's gay and he's welcomed by the
right
i believe it was sort of ridiculous
because he was just seen as a useful
tool for the right to be able to point
to and say
look we accept gay people as long as
they have all the right opinions
like for example it's bad to be gay
which was milo's opinion about himself
all along
he's been a guest on this program he
suffered through a lot of
i guess bands from different platforms
because of his
uh hateful commentary he now is
back after a big fall from grace for
appearing to sort of
play coy with uh relationships with
underage boys
i'm not saying he necessarily defended
it but the comments were certainly bad
enough that many platforms said no more
milo
he's now back and it might just be an
attempt to remain in the public eye but
he says that he has successfully gone
through
what is sometimes called and it's
disgusting
conversion therapy so-called conversion
therapy
he has been converted he has been
essentially he's saying he's been cured
of being gay
he is now part of this ex-gay community
do you even buy this i mean like i know
that we don't believe the idea of you
can be talked out of being gay you could
be talked into suppressing what are your
sort of natural preferences but uh i
know i'm not asking whether you believe
in quitting homosexuality do you even
believe
he believes this or do you think it's
just publicity
i find it hard to believe but the thing
is it's really not for us to say i mean
it's only
milo who can tell us what his sexual
orientation is it's not
up to us or our assessments on it but it
does seem to me like a desperate attempt
for attention because i feel like milo's
star peaked around
2016 2017 and then ever since he
effectively got cancelled
we haven't really heard too much from
him except for like these occasional
news stories so
maybe this is his way to try to get back
into the limelight and also try to
rebrand because maybe he
assesses that being a gay conservative
isn't really working
to for trying to appeal to more
conservative viewers so he has to come
out as a straight conservative now
um and this is his new approach for this
stuff one of the things he
says now in an interview where he
explains this is that he was quote never
wholly
at home in the gay lifestyle like even
adopting the terminology of calling it a
lifestyle is also you know something
straight out of the
conversion therapy community remember
conversion therapy
is banned for use on on children in many
states this is so damaging and toxic
he's claiming almost like he only
exaggerated i don't even know how to say
this but he's he's saying
i'll just read the quote and then we'll
try to figure out what it means he says
he quote
only leaned heavily into
being gay in public because it drove
liberals crazy to see a handsome
charismatic
intelligent gay man celebrating
conservative principles
which is of course not what drove people
crazy about milo but he's almost saying
like
i was gay to trigger the left that's
what i was thinking yeah i went gay to
own the libs
but that doesn't seem believable at all
like that would be
full-on commitment a full-on grift i
don't think that many people would be
willing to do that i don't think milo
would be willing to do it either i think
he's just genuinely gay
and i don't know if he actually has this
like different feeling on this stuff now
if he actually feels like he doesn't
want to be gay anymore or if he's just
doing this
as another grift but it just it all just
seems very strange to me
yeah the the one other thing about it is
that now he's putting all of this
under the uh catholic um reawakening
that he had saying that he he grew up in
the catholic church and now he's back
one of the things he would play up
before was that he was jewish
at least half jewish and i don't know if
that's because he has one catholic
parent and one jewish parent
you never know like what's true and
what's a lie with milo anyway not that
it really matters but it all is very
confusing
what do you think about these people who
argue against identity politics using
identity politics to make their points
like it's hypocrisy or do you think
they're able to get away with stuff like
that because
in their eyes they're just exposing how
dumb all this
identity politics stuff is on the left i
think it's just hypocrisy sort of make
an exception
no i think it's just hypocrisy i think
the second thing is just way too nuanced
and i think it's just blatant hypocrisy
yeah i feel like this also goes to show
that maybe conservatives aren't as
woke on the gay rights issue as they
would have you believe
like i think after gay marriage became
the law of the land in 2015
conservatives republicans they tried to
rebrand right away and act as if they
were never against gay marriage they
were always
for gay rights and you saw this crop of
gay republicans becoming more prominent
after that gay marriage decision but now
their stars are fading and you know milo
was one of these people and now he feels
as though he has to readjust so maybe
they're not
as opening as open to the gay community
as was once thought
no i i would certainly agree with that
and we wish milo the best he's welcome
on the show anytime to talk about this
and i would be very interested in
hearing from him but
he he's last time i invited him onto the
show he said he responded really angrily
saying like
that um something like i never cared
when they were beating him down
and now i'm just opportunistically
trying to interview him and they're
gonna come for me next and then i'll
lose my platform and
he was like mad at me i don't even
really understand what it was about but
he declined as the point to be on the
show that's weird because i know he was
turning against fellow conservatives
right but it's not like you were ever a
political ally no so
why would he care if you know people
were going after him
and you and like as if you'd be wrapped
up in the same thing when you have very
different opinions on stuff yeah i'd
have to review exactly what the language
was but it struck me as someone who was
just kind of like mad
but i'd be interested in talking to him
about this idaho is ending its powerball
lottery
and the reason they're ending it is they
fear that there's foreign participation
in the powerball lottery and
um they were debating in the iowa in the
idaho legislature whether to continue
or not they sought a change in state law
because they were expanding to include
australia this year
and britain next year but right now
idaho law only allows people
in the state to be played only allows
people in the u.s and canada to
participate in their
lottery and they are now worried about
ways in which so much foreign
involvement in the lottery could be
problematic
that they also are mad because in
australia
people could win and then australia's
very anti-gun
and so you could take idaho's tax money
which is one
in the lottery and it goes to an
australian winner and they use it to ban
guns and do anti-gun stuff but
there are also some democrats that are
concerned
about uh this as well it's not just
republicans
and um just generally concerned that a
lot of money could go to countries that
they aren't friendly with or may not
always be friendly with
kind of an unusual thing but interesting
that idaho is doing this many states run
powerball lotteries each each with it
with their own rules
yeah i'm okay with idaho doing away with
the powerball the justification
to me seems a little bit strange like i
would be less inclined to get rid of it
over this foreign
interference concern and certainly the
stuff dealing with
australia and guns i'd be more
interested in getting rid of it because
we know that it negatively affects the
poor
sure with this money you can raise a lot
for schools and
public programs but the people who buy
these lottery tickets are often
at the lowest of uh the economic rungs
and so it means that
you know it's sort of aggressive in that
way and that's why i don't think we
should have the powerball anymore
yeah there's a lot of different uh
concerns around the lottery also the
people because of the people who tend to
play the lottery
the people who win the lottery tend to
be terrible with money and
often end up either getting scammed out
of a lot of the money
or they end up losing it by making bad i
don't even necessarily want to call them
investment decisions just financial
decisions
um that that's a whole other sort of
sort of question but there is the
question you bring up pat which is
clearly the a lot of the people playing
the lottery shouldn't based on their
financial situation
but in theory a lot of people's lives
are improved
because of the money states get from the
lottery to invest in programs so
is it a net plus is it a net minus i
have no idea
well i want money to be raised for these
programs and for schools i just wanted
to come from the rich
primarily and i don't think too many
rich people are playing the lottery
certainly there are some
but usually it's it's lower class or
middle class people who feel as though
if they just buy that winning ticket
then they're going to become
millionaires and overnight they're going
to
go from owning very little to a lot and
it's that hope that drives people
to buying these lottery tickets but the
vast majority of the time it just
leads to people wasting their money and
it adds up to quite a lot over the
course of the week yes
i know people who play the powerball
uh every week i think it's like two
bucks twice a week or something like
that it's like 350 dollars for the year
and a lot of people can't afford that uh
and it's it's sort of like no big deal
and it's just kind of a fun thing but i
also know people who are regularly
buying scratch tickets
and they really can't afford it and it's
five bucks here ten bucks here and
that's really what i worry about more
than powerball
yeah that's the thing like if you can
afford it and if you don't mind losing
that
money then no harm no foul i suppose uh
but you know it's
it's it's not like you can say like oh
well if you're in a well-off situation
then it's okay to play the powerball
whereas if you're
a low income then you're not allowed to
buy these tickets you have to make this
blanket statement for everyone and
right that's why it makes sense to just
do away with it but you know other forms
of betting will persist people will
still be able to
bet on sports and you know maybe just
even make sound investments wouldn't
that be nice
that would be uh that would be a whole
whole other ball of wax that's a big
matzo ball hanging out there as some
some people like to say hey we predicted
this and it's happening
arkansas republican governor asa
hutchinson signed into law on tuesday
one of the country's most restrictive
abortion bans
and this is senate bill 6 abortion would
only be allowed in cases where it's
necessary to save the life
or preserve the health of the fetus or
mother
the law allows no exceptions for
rape or incest and performing or
attempting to perform an abortion
is considered an unclassified felony
under this bill
if you're convicted you could face a
prison sentence or a hundred thousand
dollar
fine now of course this is going to be
challenged
but that's the hope pat as we talked
about the whole
strategy on abortion was hold off on
merit garland so that trump can appoint
merrick uh scalia's replacement which
they did
puts in neil gorsuch then he gets brett
kavanaugh
then he gets amy covid barrett now he
puts three people on
and then now you do a really restrictive
abortion
law in some state it gets appealed all
the way to the supreme court and you may
have the most
favorable right wing supreme court that
could
issue a ruling that could in practice
undo the precedent of roe v wade this so
far
this was the game plan and they're doing
it right this is a real concern and it
really was that last supreme court pick
that trump got that could push this over
the edge
because i was under the impression that
john roberts if a case like this ever
made it to the supreme court would side
with the liberals right
because he often does that and of course
roe versus wade has been president for
50 years now so it's kind of hard to
overturn that
but you could have roberts now vote with
the liberals and you could still lose
this case because there are five other
conservatives who
may move to get rid of abortions and you
know that's just
the way it is i mean the conservatives
have been able to pack the courts over
the years they have
total control over the supreme court now
the way to fight back i suppose would be
to codify
roe versus wade to pass legislation
through congress and have president
biden signed
into law this uh bill that would make it
so that abortions would be legal in most
cases around the country
right but of course that could also get
challenged by courts so yeah this could
be a problem that persists with us for a
long time
and it really shouldn't be because this
should be an issue that's settled by now
and this
you're absolutely right and because
republicans
know they don't have at least for the
next two years the house the senate
or the white house it's the perfect
opportunity to try to legislate through
the courts
and create an enemy create an enemy
which is the abortionist liberals as
they often do
and i wouldn't be surprised to see a
bunch of other states do the same i
wouldn't be surprised to see multiple
appeals to the supreme court whether the
supreme court takes the cases obviously
remains to be seen they
they don't have to uh but my expectation
pat is this is not going to be the only
one of these over the next couple years
do you think if this case or a similar
one goes to the supreme court that
conservatives will
do away with roe versus wade or do you
think that there could be one more
conservative justice maybe
neil gorsuch maybe brett kavanaugh who
would side with the liberals and decide
not to do that what do you think that
we would have any hope if this does
reach the supreme court i really don't
know
i really don't know i i would like to
think so but
it's not this is the the court right now
is one where it's harder for me to
predict where
each justice will come down on different
issues things have gotten sort of wacky
and i really have no idea i would hope
so but i think there's a real risk of
roe v wade
effectively being at risk if it if a
case like this gets to the court
right there have been some issues where
these conservative justices will
surprise us
like with uh the thing about um how
gay rights and uh uh well the thing
about how gender identity and sexual
orientation will be added
yeah civil rights bill to make it so
that you can't discriminate based on
those things
um you know there have been there's been
some crossover here and there on certain
issues
but we know that abortion is the big one
for the right and i feel like they would
hold firm
uh and stick with their conservative
principles on that because they realize
that's why they're there in the first
place on the court
and you know so many evangelicals so
many people around the country want the
policy to change on this and i feel like
they may hold the line
unfortunately i i i'm worried that
you're right about that and
unfortunately
we have no control over it all we can do
is wait and see
step one is this bill in arkansas step
two will be the appeal that is already
being being put together and
uh onward and upward from there
okay tonight i will be streaming joe
biden's
presidential address to the nation in
prime time i will start at 7 30 pm
eastern
joe biden going on at 802 pm eastern not
eight
if you're gonna tune in at eight pat
you're gonna have to wait two minutes to
see joe biden because it's scheduled for
802.
i think the real question is what's
going on between 8 and 802.
i know like a video package maybe a big
introduction that's my question i'm
gonna be tuning in early for sure not
just to see your commentary but also to
see what happens then
so that'll be tonight and then we'll
have a new show and bonus show tomorrow
two more weeks of shows and then david
pakman show spring break but before any
of that i'll see everybody tonight
on the live stream the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
you